all right Laura kognito here iron law
podcast Lords of gaming dotnet with one
of the most anticipated Sony titles and
what do we have here this fine gentlemen
in the realm what's your name sir Jeff
Jeff could you tell us your role as far
as awesome makes things work as far as
from a vehicle standpoint and from a
weapon standpoint yeah this is awesome
this is awesome we got MJ the boss with
some gameplay going on so he getting
some footage off days gone so what could
you tell us about for those who do not
have a clue what days gone is he lived
under a rock what what do you what tell
us about days ago
and you've got a fight for everything
it's a big survival aspect you got to
manage your health and your bikes fuel
and everything you got to get out there
and craft all this stuff it's big
survival aspect
fun game awesome so it's actually two
components based on what you're saying
so it's not just your health it's also
your vehicle this is a key component now
what you say in reference to like
traversal around the world can you not
use the bike like tell us about that as
far as the bike as far as the vehicle
itself like you say you have to get
parts and stuff to maintain the vehicle
right yeah is it possible to not utilize
the bike at all and just kind of put
everything on now all right here we go
wow this thing is looking fantastic
and I believe the zombies here they're
caught freaker's if I remember to see
the development on from how it was first
displayed a couple of he threes though
truly you can see the improvement it's
getting vicious out here it's getting
vicious
really really good man so what portion
of what you say are we at in the game as
far as where we are right now pretty
early okay gotcha gotcha and this is our
main protagonist here now another
component that I want to ask you about
was on in reference to the the actual
human element the other other cars um
they also there's people that work
factions that work with you or against
you or how does that whole work gotcha
this thing looks fantastic
now we run this PlayStation 4 now as far
as our do we have any um specs as far as
our resolution are we trying to hit any
targets this look is looking really good
and the energies fantast have that
control Phil m'kay
feeling good alright getting nukes
actually look scripts over-the-shoulder
now as far as weapon I see we got the
pistol going on and we do we have
another variety of weapons and I see
shotgun as well yeah okay gotcha gotcha
really looks good the world looks very
wide open
getting those guys out of here take it
to the motel love good job now what
about the main character his backstory
as far as like I'm almost I'm a fan of
Sunday anarchy Hey
so I'm getting the Sons of Anarchy vibe
going oh yeah okay guys that's what I'm
gonna put it out there so I'll get the
Jax teller thing going so tell us a
little bit about our protagonist so if
we know anything about him as far as you
know what happened with this world well
by he's in the situation
[Music]
[Music]
and the story is really about him coming
from where he's at at the beginning
which is really you know he's really
upset and it's really a story of like
open can throw me doesn't Mariner how to
live in the world gosh that's awesome
man it's awesome so he got the fallen
wife and just trying to figure out the
harsh conditions of a world game looks
absolutely fantastic I'm noticing
weather effects as well we got the rain
knowing about stuff like that so I'm
assuming that's kind of old dynamic okay
so that weather even affects the actual
zombies themselves so to speak as far as
how much you would encounter in things
nature yeah alright so he's gotta find
his way into the garage mission is
called you got a death wish guys it's
couple not really really cool
trying to get in that garage can't get
it looks like that fossil type key is
something going on
it's really good
picking up some Adams got his rag
really cool now as far as like level
designs for his length what ours but as
far as anticipating as far as length of
time like far as like hours of gameplay
[Music]
so you can go off the beaten path a lot
of side quests a lot of side missions
into that nation that's awesome now as
far as on in the future I know right now
no we're trying to gear towards launch
right and again launch is looking at I'm
so used to waiting for this month all
right so this is coming all right cool
now I know I know it's early I know you
haven't hit launch yet but on again
could you talk about like maybe any
things or any things you encountered
maybe during development that made it
maybe change because I know I kind of
went through some iterations I
remembered a there's going kind of
changing focus a little bit
[Music]
any game that you're developing goes
through a lot of iteration and you know
they always say that what do you think
you're gonna build this never once you
actually build and you know any game
goes through that gotcha but we're
really happy with where we've landed
absolutely absolutely glad you're here
because again we've been waiting for it
for a long time yeah and again like you
said like I remember seeing it at a baby
III I'm gonna say it's 2017 I believe
when I first saw it I like off the Horde
thing going on and that that those
aspects are still there for yeah because
we I saw some closed-door stuff and it
looked amazing and I just like that
dynamic of being able to dictate the
horn as your own weapon map and then
utilize it against other enemies that I
think is really what makes days one
unique exactly from like the typical you
know zombie kind of a game and I mean
that's another element that I really
like that you guys have been really
taking out and nailing and knocking out
the part with it got a little bit of
melee combat action how's that a melee
feeling I'm doing
you got your badge you got a whole bunch
of things and it looks like he can
really stock up as far as supplies and
things that
he tell us a little bit more about the
craft it's a big part of the game we
have a lot of stuff just throughout the
world as you move through and collects
and as you progress through the game
you're gonna learn new recipes to build
bigger better things gotcha
and this is a big aspect of growing your
character and learning
like a Ford or something you know you
got to get through the game to learn
build new weapons it's nice to do
awesome now not one question
specifically about the crafting home you
mentioned like learning like different
type I guess recipes so to speak
is this something trial and error and
then once you learning it's kind of in
his memory bank that it's stored or it's
like set crafting items combinations
[Music]